♫♫
-These are two of our writers,
Amber and Jenny.
-I´m black!
-And I´m gay!
-And we´re both women!
-And I´m not.
So here´s how this works.
I´ll read the setups
for these jokes,
and Amber and Jenny
will read the punch lines.
Here we go.
Billboard recently
published a list
of the 30 best
lesbian love songs,
including one song
by the Indigo Girls.
-And 29 other songs
-A children´s book author
is under fire for writing
a story about a black Santa.
-A black Santa
is like a regular Santa,
except he doesn´t get there
until the 27th.
-Amber!
-Sorry.
A black Santa
is like a regular Santa,
except his packages are bigger.
[ Laughter ]
-Amber!
-Sorry.
A black Santa
is like a regular Santa,
but instead of, "Ho, ho, ho,"
he goes, "Ho, ho.
Hoe, you calling this a cookie?"
-Amber!
-Sorry. I am sorry.
Sorry.
-A lesbian in Florida
was recently told
she could not enter a nightclub
because of the shoes
she was wearing.
-Let´s get out of here!
Said the lesbian to her cat.
[ Laughter ]
-A 7-year-old girl
is currently on a mission
to hug a police officer
in all 50 states.
-So, yeah, she´s white.
[ Laughter ]
-According to a recent study,
11% of gay male couples
have experienced problems
with wedding vendors.
-While the other 89%
are wedding vendors.
-So, Jenny, what´s
the biggest difference
between a straight wedding
and a gay wedding?
-The reason
the parents are crying.
[ Laughter ]
-The African-American
History Museum
will be honored
with a Forever Stamp.
-Of course, if you want
to lick something in honor
of African-American history,
I´m right here, baby.
-I think I could
have told that one.
-I don´t think you could have.
[ Laughter ]
-That one would have
worked for me.
-´Cause you wouldn´t
have meant it.
-[ Laughs ]
A British blog
recently published
a list of slang terms
for "lesbian."
-Number-one on the list --
"Mom´s New Friend."
-So, Jenny, what´s your favorite
slang term for lesbian?
-I´d say Coach.
-No, no, no. Flannel Enthusiast.
-Oh. Seth Meyers look-alike.
-Oh, come on.
-Oh, that´s the best one.
That´s the best one.
Hey, Seth,
why don´t you tell one?
-No! I don´t think
I´d get away with it!
-Oh, come on. Just one!
-I feel like
this will end badly.
-Oh, please, Seth, please?
-Okay, okay, okay.
-Yes!
-The Boy Scouts of America
announced recently
that they will allow girls
to join their programs.
And when they heard that,
all the Boy Scouts
pitched a tent.
[ Laughter ]
-How dare you!
-You told me it would be okay!
-You should be
ashamed of yourself!
-Black women and lesbians
are liars!
♫♫
We´ll be right back with more
"Late Night," everybody.